(audience applauds)
- Please welcome one of
my favorite actresses
on planet Earth and
history, Elisabeth Moss.
(audience cheers)
(upbeat bright music)
- Hi.
This is for you.
I know you're all about your
suits, and you look so cute.
So I had to.
- I do.
So beautiful.
Look.
(Kate laughs)
- It's so good to see you.
- Oh my god, I'm so happy to
see you, I can't believe it.
- It's been way too long.
- It has been way too long.
And this is the dream.
We're hear in person.
IRL, as the kids say.
- In person.
Yes.
IRL.
- Are you comfortable?
- I think so.
- Is the pillow good?
- (laughs) I'm good.
Drew Barrymore just fluffed my pillow.
- I will fluff your pillow
until the end of time.
(Kate laughs)
All right, so, you are in...
is it true that you're
in season five right now
of "The Handmaid's Tale"?
- Yes, yes.
- Right now, right now!
(Drew screams)
(audience applauds)
And I love where it's going.
Ugh, there's just, we are all human.
And when people have been
wronged, we want to make it right.
- Yes. (chuckles)
- And it's just delicious and bitey
and fighty and everything.
What's going on?
How's the season going?
Any spoilers?
How's it going?
- It's going really well.
We're halfway through.
- Uh-huh.
She's already excited,
I haven't said anything,
you're already excited.
- My favorite show ever.
- I know, thank you.
I will say that it's a very big season.
We've been on location a lot.
We've been in the studio very little,
which for us means that it's very big.
And we're just constantly on the road.
A lot of locations.
June's journey is big.
The other characters'
journeys are very big
and June's dealing with,
what does freedom actually mean?
And can she really be free?
And what does that mean?
And where do I place my anger?
And these really big questions
that I think are also really identifiable.
- Yes, it's so true.
- Yeah.
- Whoa.
- Oh.
(Kate laughs)
Okay, well, in your new project
which is another example
of your immaculate work
and performance and style.
It's quintessential.
If you love Elisabeth
Moss, this show is for you.
"Shining Girls."
Tell us about that show.
- Yes, it's very, very
twisty, very twisty.
It's one of those shows
that the first episode
you think what you know
and then the second episode, you're like,
oh no, it's completely different.
And then the third and fourth
and so on and so forth.
So I play Kirby who works
at the Chicago Sun-Times,
she's an archivist in 1992.
Which was really fun.
And she had survived a brutal
assault six years prior
to when our show begins.
So that's like one side of the show.
And then there's another side of the show
which is she's dealing with
an ever-shifting reality.
And I mean quite literally.
Like things change around
her and she doesn't know why.
So the show is actually about
her figuring out how and why.
- And there's things that match up
to things that happen
that give her revelations.
And it goes on a ride from
there and it is so good.
It is a rollercoaster ride.
- Thank you, I appreciate that.
(upbeat bright music)